let me pull up this story here for you
guys from timcast.com Disney Affiliated
drag queen welcomes children to show
featuring simulated sex and nudity it's
not just simulated sex it is simulated
sodomy where two men go up on stage in
front of children and simulate sodomy
and um I'm surprised to see this a
little bit because here we go Katie
Porter Democrat from California said
that groomer and pedophile are just
identities and that you know people are
attacking them for their identities as
if they've committed a criminal act and
it's like well grooming is in my opinion
and you want to make an argument about
someone just being a pedophile they
haven't done anything fine but that's an
insane thing for a Democrat to say but
it's because they're moving the Overton
window first they said drag shows are
just fashion it's dancing and then once
all the left got on board and said we
that they defend these things and the
right's crazy they've now graduated to
drag shows where I can't show you the
image not on YouTube it is exposed
breasts like simulated breasts that but
like not a bra not a not a fake bust
quite literally nipples and everything
on this person's chest called tits in a
box and then there's actually a dude
wearing a thong and it and he turns
around and Giggles tea heat with his ass
to the kids and then it shows like the
spiral of his ass around him and then
you actually have two guys doing it on
stage simulating doing it on stage okay
so when here here's what I see happening
the people on the right who have
families have everything to lose and so
they don't want to take the risk the
people on the left have literally
nothing to lose so they'll risk anything
and everything that's asymmetrical
conflict and it ends with a very obvious
outcome so if you're in a short-term
perspective such as I can't lose my job
I have kids I have to feed them I
totally get it far be it for me to tell
you what to do just as long as you know
this is the world you are leaving for
your children if you're okay with that
then by all means do nothing if this is
terrifying you and and and and and
making you concerned maybe you should
consider what standing down means for
your children when they get older but
maybe you want your kids to be on stage
with these guys I don't know these kids
are watching it all happen they're
they're being groomed by overt
sexualization in these shows it is
escalating they are incrementalizing
more and more and more and this ends
with them actually abusing the kids in
these events it started with a drag show
where our drag queen dances the next
thing we saw was it's not going to lick
itself then we saw children taking their
clothes off on stage for fermented a gay
bar now you have them simulating sodomy
in front of children and they were what
do you think happens next I hope you're
happy about what the world will be if
you don't want to be involved okay I'm
not telling you what to do because I get
it risk is scary and I mean that
seriously but just as long as you
understand this is what awaits your
children
yeah this one was um the worst we so
defend our kids Texas my organization
sent Taylor Hansen out to this
particular drag show to get the footage
um I re I did the research on this it's
a drag queen Christmas tour they've got
like I think 38 different stops across
the country that they're going to
um way more than I'm comfortable with in
Texas I think that was four or five just
in Texas and um the thing about this one
is that
on the ticketing website it did say all
age is welcome it did in most cases it
did give some sort of a very very soft
warning like this is adult so just be
careful but all age is welcome so
typically the the response that I get
from the left is well they did give some
sort of warning okay well why then in
this particular show did they constantly
Target the children because we have
video after video after video of all of
these performers speaking to the
children in the crowd calling them up to
the stage interviewing them putting them
on the mic all while they're also
explaining there was one part where one
of the the performers talked about a
sexual act that they had with their
father's boss and detailed it right and
then went around the audience and had
the audience share their favorite sex
stories no wings with children with
children knowing that there were
children in the audience they knew this
because they were conversing with them
on the microphone so for everyone who
wants to say well it's not the drag
queen's fault they didn't add their just
saying all ages welcome just because
they want to be welcoming and they want
to be inclusive they could very very
easily make this 18 and up 21 and up if
they wanted to there's a reason why they
called out to those children they called
them up to the stage they received tips
from them there is a reason why they are
doing that yeah in this particular video
too that you mentioned specifically I
think it's that person with the the
bazunkas out that clearly was
interviewing yes a small child and what
the bazangas with I I don't think I
don't know I I I don't remember but I
remember seeing this clip going uh you
know around on Twitter specifically
asking a child who was barely able to
speak what's your favorite part of the
show child's like nothing yeah I feel
sorry for these kids
parents thinking bringing them out to
this and then and again the police just
have no upside to do anything about it
but this over the sexualization what
does it do to children it ruins their
possibilities of having cohesive
relationships ruins their possibility of
having family members gets them hooked
onto adult contents Rob their innocence
gets rid of their ability to have a
childhood so that there's so many layers
to this that essentially for me at the
end of the day boiled down to a
depopulation agenda some people might
say it's a degeneracy agenda whatever it
is this is this is sick this is not good
and this is not something children
should be around it can be both right
like it can be a depopulation agenda at
the top and just a degeneracy problem at
you know with at the bottom yeah I think
that that's because a lot of people keep
asking why do children need to be be
there but why do guys have to dress in
front of children to be the bigger
question why do you as an adult male
have to do this in front of children and
if you didn't like it you wouldn't
Target the children in the show just
simple question
what would happen if the bazunga's
dancer went to a grade school playground
and just walked around
at this point it'd probably be tolerated
no no it would think so a father would
get up or if there was a father a lot of
families or father when like we can't
show the images of what they did on
YouTube because YouTube will say this is
not Advertiser friendly but for some but
the issue is police even though it is
already illegal won't do anything about
it so when I say something like this I
am outright abolish the police 100 this
is already child sexual exploitation and
the cops aren't doing anything about it
so why have cops if they won't even stop
that in Texas yeah Instagram took took
it down Instagram took videos and photos
of this down but but but but it's okay
they also took down like didn't Taylor
put up like they removed my post and
it's like a smaller version and they
took that one down too like it doesn't
make any sense I think what's strange to
me is Most states have laws against like
you can't show children pornography
right you're not allowed to show them
simulated sexual acts so when cops say
well there's nothing we can do about it
like that can't possibly be true because
this is within at least in Most states
the definition of something that is not
allowed they are choosing not to pursue
it and whether that's because you know
there's no criminal complaint by the
parents who bought tickets and brought
their children or you know what is the
company going to do be like oh I think
we made a mistake please prosecute us
like you need you need someone to be
complaining theoretically although the
cops do have the right you know law
enforcement could theoretically
press charges they're just opting not to
Texas yeah I know I know and that and
that is what is so infuriating to me as
well I'm like if this is if and this is
what I think part of their plan is in
pushing this in Texas because some of
the most egregious ones that we've done
the one at ebb and flow that you guys
probably saw with the guy that was uh
dancing to the sexually explicit p word
song with a young girl that was right
there
um I I took that video and I kept
telling myself how in the world is this
happening in Texas and you know you got
to believe that they are so arrogant
that they think if we can get this done
in Texas where can we not get this done
right because Florida
that's the only place right that's the
only place but I think it's like if you
are a liberal in Texas you see yourself
as like someone in occupied territory
yeah you're being so Progressive by
taking your child to this and how dare
these backwards conservative people
wrong this thing that should be I don't
know what fun I'm not sure what the
adjective is for them but like I think
it's to connect with these people who
are so kind of moving down a radical
path especially in their parenting that
they feel as though they are morally
correct and when there is Backlash they
double down on what they do someone
should interview these parents and just
be like after the show why are you
bringing your child here why do you
think this is okay I I would I I'm
curious because they're either brain
dead they're they're you know they're
they're either you know fluoride brained
out or or just totally out of it or just
really bad people well they will be in
Dallas tomorrow night and maybe I just
might happen to be there asking them
those questions yeah where where are the
police
uh oftentimes they are called so they
show up but usually they get stuck
trying to maintain peace between antifa
who always shows up and the protesters
who always show up and they uh they say
there's no violation they say there's no
violence I don't think they get stuck we
can't do well right but uh they they I
gotta say this I think the cops are are
probably in on it I completely agree
with you and so for us the the most
reasonable solution for us is to go to
the legislators and say you need to
strengthen the language and make sure
that it is clear that this is child
abuse make sure that it is prohibited
what else do you do in this moment to
protect kids so well I'll start with
this
we often talk about how uh the law is is
less relevant than culture there are
laws on the books in I can't remember
what city it was I was reading a book
and it was like putting a pie in your
windowsill is illegal unless it's like
Tuesday or something and it was a law
that used to be there because of wild
animals being attracted to the small
town but now that's a big city it makes
no sense why you can't be on the you
know top of your building you know put a
pie out the window so no cop will
enforce that law we are at the point
where police are completely okay with
this there in New York there's an
interesting cultural thing where women
are allowed to walk around topless
but a lot of these cops are more
conservative so there's one particular
woman who's morbidly obese and she walks
around with her massive bazangas
flopping around and she gets arrested
all the time and then immediately files
a lawsuit and wins instantly and gets
several thousand dollars because the
cops see her and say ma'am you can't do
that and she goes yes I can they say
you're under arrest then the cops find
out it's actually allowed
see culturally among those cops in New
York they see it and say I have to stop
it there's no law they know of right
it's just wrong to them right the cops
here was a San Antonio uh Austin Austin
this one was Austin so the cops in
Austin this is perfectly fine just like
the parents think so no no law that
could be written is going to make the
cops enforce this but if you you need
Abbott to send in state troopers yeah
yeah well I mean you're not wrong I have
been to some where the cops do see I can
see it on their face it does seem like
they want to do something but they feel
like their hands are tied because of
their superiors I'm not I'm not covering
for them
for them that's an excuse right well
right like I've seen I've seen cops
arrest people for nothing I watched a
video out of Florida where a guy got
arrested because he had a he was a blind
guy with a walking cane and they're
watching two dudes simulate sodomy in
front of children like well you know
this one's too ambiguous for us yeah are
you kidding me well there's people who
pee outside they get charged with
indecent exposure right yeah that
happens routinely all the time perhaps
in in Texas want this that's the only
explanation well more importantly with
all the the events that I've attended
it's you know as you would expect it's
almost exclusively what appears to be
single mothers uh taking their young
children no fathers usually right no
fathers and and what is so fascinating
to me is I'm like
where the hell are the dads in the
community why are they not coming here
they are all walking in they're not
screaming it down they're not doing all
of the things that I would want and
expect you know my husband to do if this
came to my community and you know my
child or other my friend's children were
participating in it or whatever uh where
is that urgency of the men in these
communities to say we're not letting you
do this in our town it's it's really
frightening to me but men who do that
are you know toxically masculine and
they're not who cares I don't care I
think it'd be a good thing but I'm just
saying that like the same way that cops
who might in their gut be like this is
wrong I can see this is wrong but I
don't know how to move forward because I
don't think I have any law to arrest
them I don't know who I address whatever
I think men who are in these communities
like are you gonna tell if you're if you
have a sister who has a young child
you're a man who's going to take your
niece or nephew to one of these shows
like do you say like no you can't take
them and start some family riff like I
think people afraid to speak up I agree
with you but I think that there is so
much I I have seen cops arrest people by
going uh you can't go there it's a
frozen Zone and the person says what's
Frozen zone mean it means you can't go
there and then the person goes okay and
so it's walking you're under arrest I've
seen people get arrested for resisting
arrest meaning they weren't actually
being arrested there was nothing to
resist and they're being arrested for
the act of resisting arrest that wasn't
happening and these cops are like well
you know they are shaking big fake tits
in front of children and simulating sex
acts which is child exploitation but uh
far be it for me to know the law I was
arrested seven times seven times I have
to go to jail why routinely asking
questions right and so so to see this
level this is why I have a lot of my
points and viewpoints because seeing the
absurdity in our society where you get
in trouble for asking a politician a
question but you show your junk to small
kids that somehow is okay it's not I
mean what are the laws that prevent
children from entering strip clubs right
like why is this any different right
right well it's not I mean the LGBT
community is now I think exempt from
laws regarding child exploitation and
child sexual abuse I mean that that's
the only conclusion that I can come to
and if people are not willing to stand
up and do what's right when it comes to
sexual abuse of children like what what
are they willing to stand up for imagine
being a cop
but also being like you know willfully
and knowingly only enforcing you know
like Revenue generation through tickets
and arresting you know legitimate
protesters while ignoring antifa and
this yeah like I can only assume the
good cops retired defund the police
worked and the cops that are left are
totally on board with it that's what
they wanted they wanted a police force
that would be subservient we saw this in
Seattle when a bunch of antifa people
were like approaching it out with
weapons and he was backing up and a cop
vehicle pulls up gets out grabs the
victim and arrests him and then
apologizes to antiva that's where we're
at thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time